i think nutrition is probably the most
important thing you can do i think
especially now through the years you
know the the margins are getting smaller
and smaller everyone's you know at top
of level everyone's doing the correct
thing to have and everyone's doing you
know 100 so when it gets that level and
that one
you know you need to do everything you
can and
i think if you don't prepare properly
you get found out pretty quick you know
you might feel good you might feel fine
but then once you get two three weeks in
into a banter anyway you notice it you
know you guys start getting sluggish and
you can't follow the bigger taxi you
need to you can't make your own moves
and you you just kind of uh you know
fade away everyone in the world at least
whoever rides the bike in athlete is
experience a bunk at some point
um it's one of the most horrific
feelings you can you can ever have while
you're exercising so uh
we try and board it as much as possible
you know not just in racing but in
training you can go out and do a really
hard day and you know push yourself to
the limit and you come on when you and
you're completely completely dead so
yeah you just need to keep on top of it
and and make sure you're feeling it
efficiently or else you won't get the
best of yourself